HAVE NO INTENTIONS OF FIRING
BOB MUELLER.
>> Laura: OKAY, GUYS, DON'T
BE DECEIVED FOR A NANO
SECOND BY THE DEMOCRATS'
DRAMATIC WARNING THAT THE
PRESIDENT BETTER NOT FIRE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR MUELLER.
BETTER NOT DO IT.
DON'T DO IT.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY HOPING HE
WILL DO JUST THAT.
NOW THAT THE CREDIBILITY OF
THE RUSSIA PROBE IS
TARNISHED AFTER ALL THE
BOMBSHELL REPORTING WE HAVE
BEEN DOING ON THIS SHOW.
ACROSS A COUPLE OF GREAT
NEWS OUTLETS, THE ANTI-TRUMP
MUELLER MAY BE THE DEMOCRATS
ONLY HOPE AT THIS POINT.
THERE IS ONLY ONE PROBLEM
FOR THEM.
THE PRESIDENT ISN'T FALLING
FOR IT.
HE OUTSMARTS THEM EVERY
TIME.
JOINING US NOW TO ANALYZE
KEN STARR WITH THE
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL AND THE
WHITE WATER INVESTIGATION HE
IS JOINING US FROM NEW YORK
AND IN SUNNY FLORIDA ALAN
DERSHOWITZ HARVARD LAW
PROFESSOR.
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK "TRUMPED
UP."
YOU GO FROM MARTHA'S
VINEYARD TO MIAMI BEACH.
ANYTHING ELSE?
MY GOODNESS.
GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
HAPPY HOLIDAYS, MERRY
CHRISTMAS.
LET'S START WITH YOU, JUDGE
STARR.
YOU JUST WROTE A PIECE THAT
THINGS YOU ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT IN THIS INVESTIGATION.
YOU STILL RESPECT MUELLER
AND ROSENSTEIN.
HAVE YOU SOME ISSUES.
BUT I WANT TO START ON THIS
DRAMATIC DIRE ARE SERIES OF
WARNINGS.
SAID NOT GOING TO FIRE
MUELLER.
HE SAID IT MULTIPLE TIMES.
DRUM BEAT CONTINUES.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S
ABOUT.
IT'S A CUL-DE-SAC.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT GOING
TO FIRE BOB MUELLER.
HE IS BEING ADVISED TO.
VERY WRONG HEADEDLY YOU NEED
TO FIRE BOB MUELLER.
BAD ADVICE.
WRONG THING TO DO.
I DON'T THINK THE PRESIDENT
IS GOING TO FALL FOR IT IN
FACT, WE HEAR FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE.
WE HEAR FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE'S LAWYERS AND
PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS NOT
GOING TO DO IT WOULD JUST BE
TERRIBLE.
WE DON'T NEED ANOTHER
SATURDAY NIGHT MASSACRE.
SHOULD BOB MUELLER HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED?
IT'S A SERIOUS QUESTION.
I WOULD SAY IN MAY WE SHOULD
NOT HAVE A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
WE OVER CRIMINALIZE SO MUCH
OF LIFE AND OUR POLITICS
TOGETHER.
WE NEED TO STOP THAT AND SO
I'M ALSO VERY CONCERNED
APPOINTMENT OF YET ANOTHER
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
I THINK IT'S ALL WRONG.
>> Laura: LET'S GO TO ALAN
DERSHOWITZ.
GET THE SENSE THAT THE
THERE IS NOTHING HAPPENING,
AT LEAST NOT YET ON THE
TO KEEP THE FUMES GOING AND
THIS IS ALL THEY HAVE.
ALL DAY ON THE OTHER
NETWORKS.
THAT'S ALL THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
>> RIGHT.
>> MY LIBERAL COLLEAGUES ON
THE LEFT HAVE BEEN PROVED
IMPAIR
IMEMIR
DOWN THE TRAVEL BAN.
THEY UPHELD IT.
TODAY THE FEDERAL JUDGE SAID
NONSENSICAL ARGUMENT.
THEY WERE WRONG ABOUT FLYNN.
THEY ARE WRONG ABOUT FIRING
MUELLER.
THEY HAVE JUST BEEN WRONG.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE I AM
SMARTER THAN THEY'RE.
I HAVE BEEN RIGHT AND THEY
ARE WRONG.
THEY PUT HOPE OVER REALITY.
I'M AN ANALYST.
I'M CALLING IT AS I SEE IT.
SIDES ARE PLAYING.
TRUMP SIDE IS PLAYING
SMARTER.
KEEPING PRESSURE ON MUELLER,
QUESTIONING HIS INTEGRITY.
QUESTIONING WHETHER HE
SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN A
WARRANT.
THEY ARE HOPING THAT PUTTING
PRESSURE ON HIM, HE HAS SUCH
IN A CLOSE CASE TO REPORT
THE TRUMP SIDE.
AND THE OTHER SIDE OF
PLAYING.
THEY ARE SAYING IF WE PUSH
HARD ENOUGH AND SAY HE IS
GOING TO FIRE HIM, IS HE
GOING TO FIRE HIM, HE WILL
FIRE HIM.
MAYBE WE WILL GOAD HIM IN TO
FIRING HIM.
RIGHT NOW THE TRUMP SIDE IS
COMING OFF BETTER.
THEY HAVE MUELLER WHERE THEY
WANT HIM.
AT THIS POINT.
>> Laura: NO, NO, NO.
THE FIRING COMEY WASN'T THE
BEST CHOICE, OBVIOUSLY.
>> THAT WAS NOT A SMART
MOVE.
>> Laura: I WANT TO GO TO
YOU URANIUM ONE REOPEN OF
THE INVESTIGATION THAT JEFF
SESSIONS HAS ANNOUNCED LOOKS
LIKE THEY ARE GOING TO LOOK
AT THAT ALL ANEW.
YOU ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE OF THE NUMBER OF
CONNECTIONS FROM THAT DEAL
TO THE CLINTON FOUNDATION
SPECIFICALLY.
TELL US WHAT THE BIG RED
THIS MULTIYEAR PROCESS BY
WHICH NOW THE TRANSACTION
GIFTS TO THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
$31 MILLION WAS THE FIRST
GIFT.
AFTER THE FIRST PART OF THE
DEAL WAS SIGNED IN
KAZAKHSTAN BACK IN 2005.
THEN GIFTS KEPT COMING IN
FROM SENIOR OFFICIALS FROM
ACQUISITION.
SO I'M VERY DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE TIMING.
IN RUSSIA THE RUSSIA
CONNECTION.
I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN IN FAVOR
OF TRANSPARENCY.
I THINK WE NEED TO BE
CAUTIOUS ABOUT CRIMINAL,
NEED TO GET THE FACTS OUT.
>> Laura: ALAN.
>> I AGREE COMPLETELY.
I COMPLETELY AGREE.
NONPARTISAN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATORY COMMISSION
LIKE 9/11 WHICH WASN'T
POINTING FINGERS AT PEOPLE
CRIMINALLY BUT ITS GOAL WAS
RUSSIA'S INVOLVEMENT IN
ECONOMY.
AND THEN MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM HOW TO
STOP RUSSIA FROM INFLUENCING
THROUGH A SPECIAL COUNSEL
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS OF THE
GRAND JURY.
NON-INDICTMENT OF SOME LOW
HANGING FRUIT.
>> Laura: ALAN, DO YOU THINK
IT'S INTERESTING AT THE VERY
AND MUELLER THEY WERE ALL
INVOLVED IN ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER IN THAT ROSENSTEIN
INVESTIGATION WHEN THEY
FIRST APPROVED THE DEAL.
THEY LOOKED INTO THE -- THEY
EVERYTHING AT THE
DEPARTMENT.
>> REMEMBER, THEY COME FROM
TOTALLY DIFFERENT
ANY POLITICAL INTERESTS IN
COMMON.
MUELLER IS A REPUBLICAN.
ROSENSTEIN WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT HIS POLITICS WAS.
HE WAS APPOINTED BY OBAMA,
HAVING BEEN APPOINTED
PREVIOUSLY.
THE IDEA OF CLINTON GETTING
A HALF A MILLION DOLLARS,
GEORGE BUSH THE 1ST GOT FEES
LIKE THAT WHEN HE SPOKE IN
JAPAN.
FORMER PRESIDENTS GET, BIG,
BIG FEES WHEN THEY SPEAK.
AGAIN, I DON'T WANT TO POINT
THE FINGER OF
CRIMINALIZATION ON ANYBODY.
I WANT TO SEE LIKE KEN WANTS
TO SEE TRANSPARENCY.
TO SEE.
THAT'S THE WAY DEMOCRACY
WORKS.
>> Laura: WHEN A RUSSIAN
INTEREST THROUGH CANADIAN
PURCHASE IS ABLE TO GET
CONTROL OF 20% OF OUR
URANIUM INTERESTS.
WITH PEOPLE WITH INTEREST IN
THE TRANSACTION OR CONNECTED
TO THE TRANSACTION.
YOU CAN ASK A PERSON ON THE
STREET AND THEY WOULD SAY
THAT'S A BAD IDEA.
SOMEONE WHO HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE LAW OR COMMITTEE
ON FOREIGN INVESTMENT, THEY
WOULD SAY GOSH, THAT SEEMS
REALLY STUPID, IN MY VIEW.
I WILL LET YOU CLOSE TOUT.
>> MY FOCUS ON FACT ENORMOUS
GIFTS TO THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
IT'S NOT WHETHER THERE WAS A
PROCESS, NINE AGENCIES
APPROVE IT AND SO FORTH.
IT MAY HAVE BEEN EXACTLY THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
WHY WERE THESE GIFTS
ENORMOUS YEAR AFTER YEAR
AFTER YEAR TO THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
HAVE A RUSSIAN INTEREST.
EVERYONE IS ALWAYS AFRAID OF
URANIUM STAKE.
OH THAT COULD HAVE BEEN A
GOOD THING?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW YOU
THINK THAT COULD BE A GOOD
THING.
>> I THINK IT'S VERY CLEAR
THAT COUNTRIES LIKE
KAZAKHSTAN AND OTHERS
HONESTLY BELIEVE YOU NEED TO
WONDERFUL WORK, AIDS, THEY
SPEND EVERY PENNY ON DOING
GOOD.
WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT IS